hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca I'm monster on her world
against it are gonna be talking about
how to get the new Mughal weapon and the
new Pookie outfit bacon behemoth and all
that good stuff at this video so as
always like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe for new I cover the solo gods
a Monster Hunter world which we'll get
into in a bit as well as the weekly
event quests and new tutorials and tips
and guides and stuff like that to make
everybody a better Monster Hunter volt
player so that let's get started with
today's video so to get this you have to
complete the whole collaboration for the
Final Fantasy X Monster Hunter wolf
collab first start talking with the
serious handler once you enter she's
gonna have a blue marker at estera she
would give you all the quests for this
entire collab the first is a visitor
from another world which has you
fighting a giant Kulu yaku which is a
pain in the ass by the way afterwards
once you complete that you'll be getting
another quest called legendary beast
where you have to fight behemoth and
just basically repel him for a bit it's
not that hard because you do get nine
faint opportunities so it's really not
that hard after that's done report to
her once again to get the final quest
where you actually fight and defeat
behemoth once done you will unlock the
bacon behemoth clothing for Pugi and
moogles weapon for your palico of course
the Pookie outfit doesn't have any stats
but for the Palika weapon it's a rarity
eight weapon with 40 melee and 55 damage
on ranged blunt attack type 360 element
and average eldershield zero affinity
and 12 defense bonus so honestly not a
bad weapon at all to be honest let me
know what you guys think about this
weapon in the comments below if you guys
are having trouble trying to defeat
behemoth I do have a guide which I'll
link at the end of this video so you can
check that out if you're having trouble
he is a pretty tough fight but I did
manage to put a guide and try to give it
as comprehensive as I can for the
monster but yeah the guys it's going to
be the end of the beach' to go hopefully
you guys did enjoy it like the V if he
did subscribe if he knew like I said I
covered the solo guides of every monster
and monster on our world
tips and tricks to make everyone a
better Monster Hunter player and new
events and new guides and stuff like
that my two most recent videos will be
on screen in a bit if you guys want to
check that out with that guys okay
yesterday
big marks in the video he's out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]